okay the other game yeah um
patrick mahomes i and my theory is
playoff patrick mahomes is better than
regular season patrick mahomes yeah and
he rises to we're going to this this is
going to be his career we're going to
take him for granted in the regular
season and then playoff pat is going to
show up and we're going to be like oh
where was that guy been and he's going
to be as incredible as he ever is when
the season is riding on the outcome of
one game yes no i know but let's not
make sure you make him sound like he
sucked in the regular season or
something okay he didn't know but he's
clearly better you're right clearly
better in the postseason you're right
there's there's you know
it's like kansas city i don't know it's
just them they seem to focus in a little
bit more
but that game
the offense for kansas city mike i mean
it's kind of what we saw on tv and we
talked about yesterday just when you
watch back that film you just go
when they play like that and attack that
way and then he's able to be patient
right and go okay i'm not going to force
the ball you want to play these soft
zone coverages here's kelsey underneath
for six and now he runs for 10. you know
here's here's uh michael hardman
underneath and he runs for eight more
yards you know that's when they become
unstoppable and andy and the offense
mike i mean it was just an onslaught of
movement formations
a lot of different ways to throw the
football and then to the point you just
made
the man just he doesn't really miss any
throws i mean he just doesn't miss any
throws oh oh you're going to take away
the big play from us this game i'm only
going to get one chance to throw the
ball down the field it was the first
third down of the game he threw a strike
on the post corner of the hill right he
dropped it but it just shows you their
versatility oh we don't need we can't
make big plays this week no big deal
i'll just dink and dunk your butts all
day long and what i love about it mike
is they don't call dink and dunk plays
andy reids figured out how to stress
people out where
he sends you know
tyree kill deep and now it's you know
one of the other receivers in the
mid-range and travis kelsey's the
underneath guy so now you're going whoa
they're way deep and he's of course
looking deep thinking the throw deep and
now he throws it underneath the route
and that gets eight or nine yards and
they're just they're they're so
dangerous and unstoppable that way on
the offensive side of the ball
and i think part of it too is the
regular season mentality of the opposing
defense is hey this is our chance to go
show what we can do against patrick
mahomes maybe there's a little looseness
maybe a greater commitment to creativity
you're going to take chances when when
your season's riding on it i think
knowing that mahomes and company are up
next it it it can maybe be a little more
restricting yeah and right and
nerve-wracking than it is in the regular
season because in the regular season you
know got a game the next week win or
lose we we move on
josh allen yeah i got the question
yesterday what happened to our boy blue
what did you see did he have a bad day
or was it the chiefs defense is better
than we give him credit no that's the
story of the game i think is the the
chiefs defense and their performance i
mean we know mahomes and kill you know
hill and kelsey are awesome right we
know that that's great but the defense
again you know just another thing mike
we say it every week oh i don't know can
they stop this passing game and josh
allen and all that oh that's right they
stopped it um spagnolo is incredibly
creative
like we talk about you know the packers
the packers bucks game the kansas city
chiefs d-line whoop the crap out of the
bill's offensive line there's just no
other way to say that
and they did a good job of kind of
taking away lanes for allen for the most
part to be able to run up to and then
get on the outside and do things like
that for the most part of the day you
know they made him escape up and outside
and then that allowed frank clark and
the other guys to chase him down to
where he couldn't set up and regain
himself to throw a laser somewhere in
the field but spagnolo and mike the way
he calls plays they're one of the most
deceptive pre-snap defenses in football
showing you one thing and then you snap
the ball and it's another thing
he's got a great creative timely blitzes
and
the biggest thing mike more than
anything is when they played man-to-man
and just rushed the front four buffalo
couldn't separate
you know buffalo could not separate and
kansas city's dbs have been really good
down the stretch of the season they're
healthy and man they were all over those
guys
and the one thing about showing you one
thing and doing something else you
better have defensive players who are
sufficiently skillful to get to where
they would have been definitely if the
look had meshed with what actually
happened because that's why you do it
yeah position to do a certain thing and
then you gotta sprint over here because
that's where you were going to be if you
were showing the true look so they got
guys you talked about the secondary
yesterday under rated yeah and under
appreciated secondary led by our guy
tyron matthews hey
we got a long way to go before we make
our pick right in super bowl 55. and for
me the knee jerk is hey i picked the
buccaneers to win the super bowl before
the season began so i have to pick them
but you know what i thought they'd be
facing the patriots not the chiefs it's
a different analysis
when you're facing the chiefs and i
think about that chiefs team when
they're firing all cylinders and they're
in a team in the nfl that can beat them
uh we talked about it yesterday there
was never a moment after the chiefs took
the lead
down from nine nothing up 14-9 there was
never an instant never a second where i
thought the bills are gonna win this
game yeah the one question of what's the
final score they had the nine nothing
and they had to go for it on fourth down
on that one on that first drive when
they were going down to get seven points
that was the only like okay are they
gonna make it on this play oh they got
it all right yup they're good all right
see you later you know but
but mike i mean yes i'm picking the
chiefs uh i'm not picking what i've said
all year i'm not picking against the
chiefs until i start seeing them losing
these type of games i can't go against
them so that's not gonna happen but
the little crack in the door
no eric fisher doesn't sound like
mitchell schwartz is gonna be back
that d-line we just talked about who who
ran over the packer's o-line
vida vey is back
that to me
will be the the the game that is going
to be i i almost look at it like it's
like um
you know 2007 patriots and brady vice
versa here all week that's all the bucks
the lion's gonna hear we can't win this
game unless you get to my homes we can't
win this game unless you get they're
gonna be foaming out the mouth when the
game starts and who can handle that you
know that rush better is is gonna be a
big part of the game for me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports